the gray skies looked ominous but the
threat of rain could not keep the crowds
away
[Applause]
and this is why they came
a pageant
unlike any before it
slightly surreal i mean your life
flashes before you it's a chance to see
all the people that you've loved growing
up with really all through your life
wonderful there's a great atmosphere to
it it's in the air it's palpable
the feeling in the air of joy and
elation having
finally we're together again after such
a difficult time and i think when the
queen said we'll meet again and we'll
meet now
we can feel it
[Music]
this was one of the seven open top
double deckers that joined the
procession
each one of these seven buses represents
great change in culture in fashion and
music and politics in fact every aspect
of our lives but there has been one
constant in all of those 70 years
this was a time to let down their hair
and their celebrity guard to enjoy and
to be part of the spectacle it's just
very special isn't it never happen again
obviously not certainly not for me it's
a wonderful occasion you know and
you know the crowds have turned out the
weather's been firm fine
some seven thousand performers made up
the three kilometer long carnival
procession
it was a showcase of the best of british
engineering
sports
military
among the traditional
a celebration of the modern diverse
country the queen now reigns over
the dancing was fantastic all the bikes
the the dances the cars just everything
is brilliant absolutely incredible i
came from canada just to see this and
it's beyond amazing it's been brilliant
trip through down memory lane and
through history it's been fantastic
[Music]
tens of thousands who came and the
millions who celebrated on their streets
are testament to the queen's
undiminished popularity
this giant dragon is said to embody the
powers of the young princess elizabeth
her strength
her wisdom
and her power
and this is what has made the queen
endure seven long decades
and for that the people here were truly
grateful
archers joshie sky news
central london